good morning John welcome to Hank green
sits on the floor of a hotel room in
Memphis Tennessee here's an event going
on here it's for people who run and own
independent bookstores and fascinating
very cool to talk to all these weird
people who work very hard I'm here
basically to tell them to like my book I
guess I look that they cannot currently
read but it's coming out September 25th
it's got a release date John I've always
wanted to write a book is a lie I for a
long time have wanted people to read a
book that I wrote is more accurate and
I've analyzed this and I think it's
because when I read books what I've read
books they have an outsized impact on me
this of course happens with other media
but for me most of the creations that I
have consumed that have deeply changed
the way I see the world have been books
like it's a cliche that you lose
yourself in a book but that doesn't mean
that it's not extremely profound like
the act of actually losing yourself like
I know what that is I know what it's
like for the world to disappear around
me and for all the words to be turning
into this virtual reality experience in
my mind imagining that I could be a
person who would do that to someone else
someday it was mostly the hubris of
youth like you see somebody doing
something amazing and you're like I can
do that amazing thing to really you
don't want to do all the stuff that's
necessary to get there you just want to
have had it happen and over the years I
have written a lot but I have mostly
written nonfiction I've read written
hundreds of thousands of words of essays
that have been turned into video blogs
and honestly I've written probably over
a hundred thousand words of tweets but I
also did start fiction projects and then
abandoned them several times and then
finally a few things fit together and I
realized that I was writing something
that was actually going to get finished
there's a moment and in songwriting
where I feel that way where I'm like oh
I have this song I just need to put in
the work for the song to be finished and
that's way before you finish the song
the first thing that happened is I found
a character at first just one but then
others later that I cared about really
deeply and I needed I needed to know her
story I just got caught up in her the
way I get caught up in a good book there
was no way to finish reading her story
without writing it a second piece which
was maybe first but like wasn't as
important was finding scenes these
moments in her life that
were so bizarre and wrenching that I
needed other people to know about them
so I had those two things going through
the book and I kept stopping and it
wasn't getting done and then I found a
third thing that pushed me all the way
through to the end I realized that there
were a number of things that I really
wanted to say that I was pretty
qualified to talk about that I couldn't
fit into any of my current methods for
communicating with people like it wasn't
gonna be a four minute long videos about
how the internet radicalizes us about
how Fame is so destructive and
dehumanizing and like the intensity of
the responsibility that having power
brings and how overwhelming and
crippling that can be and also how
having power makes you want to use your
power to get more power so a bunch of
stuff so that along with the knowledge
that I was gonna be able to get agents
and publishers to read this book because
I'm John Green's brother thanks for that
John as I think how I managed to sit
down and write a book over and over
again until it was done I'm very pleased
and honored and proud that I am gonna
have this thing in the real world I feel
very lucky John thank you for all of
your support and your kind words about
the book I'll see you on Tuesday
quick questions yes you can't pre-order
the book you could do it at your local
bookstore you can do it at links in the
description it'll definitely be coming
out all at the same time in Canada the
US and the UK I think also Australia it
will also be in these languages the
release dates for those languages might
not be September 25th I don't know yet
not all pre-orders will be signed John
set unrealistic expectations and I'm
bringing it back down to reality and if
you're an audio book person there will
be an audio book as well released at the
same time and I will be around in the
comments if you have other questions